what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
as you can hear the devil is trying to
get me but it ain't going to get me
it's trying to bring me down i don't get
sick i ain't got time to be sick
and the sickness ain't gonna get me but
i'm here with plano we both got
the uniform on as you know this actually
is public wreck if you don't know this
is also oh wait no this is not wait
this is public record it feels a little
scoop it feels a little scuba-y
this is public wreck too all right nice
don't forget block five is now the
sponsor of lunch money public grass
is not a sponsor but they got a little
shout out there uh
lunch money you can go to blockfly.com
and
get an account where you can earn up to
eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account
or you can sign up for the wait list for
the bitcoin rewards credit card get a
regular credit card you swipe it you get
bitcoin background then cashback or
airline miles
go to block5.com i'm an investor
it's awesome i promise it's awesome go
sign up wifi.com
what's up all right seven minutes we're
gonna rip through this
bitcoin exchange kraken considers going
public after
record trading volumes in the first
quarter it's considering going public
via direct listing in 2022
after bitcoin's rally led to record
trading
volumes kraken is an og
jesse is an og it's i think it's one of
the largest and oldest bitcoin exchanges
in the world
record growth record profits
and therefore of course they're going to
try to go public the fact that they're
gonna wait till 2022
they got some work to do between now and
then but it makes a ton of sense
i love kraken go to kraken.com they're a
sponsor of the podcast
let's go check them out there and uh go
get your little cracking account go buy
some cryptos let's go
awesome all right well well
well okay impossible foods is also in
talks to list
on the stock market impossible foods you
know like the fake meat situation
is preparing for a public listing which
could value the plant-based burger maker
at around 10 billion dollars or more
i don't know what the future i love meat
you guys know i love meat
i don't know what the future of meat
looks like but i know
that people love plant-based you look
like a
this little v thing is a little weird
we'll have to talk about it
all right little cleavage
all right go on the devil is out to get
me today but it ain't gonna kill me
uh impossible foods no-brainer of course
there's going to be plant-based food in
the future 10 billion dollars
everybody's trying to go public why
they're trying to go public
because when there's a bull market you
want to jump in you want to
ride that tailwind they're going to keep
printing trillions and trillions of
dollars in pumping stock prices
what do we think the risks are with
impossible foods
like in terms of the ipo uh the food
isn't healthy over the long term they
haven't studied a long time that doesn't
really matter for their ipo does it oh
for the ipo no
there's no risk for the ipo twitter you
know how they're building a clubhouse
competitor
apparently they discussed buying
clubhouse for four billion dollars hot
take
anyone could buy a clubhouse right now
for 10 billion dollars and it's still
gonna be a good investment
you think yes of course well ironically
enough clubhouse is now looking to raise
at a four billion dollar valuation
so wait why is that funny of course they
are
like they just the market validates
someone's will to pay for billions that
must be what they're worth
it makes sense it makes a ton of sense
actually and like i said
10 billion it still would be undervalued
in my opinion if
they can continue to scale they had two
and a half million users sign up in the
month of march
like the thing is popping yup next yep
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing youtube
all right paulina is trying to read the
article okay
so do you hear the devil coming from a
voice
so there's a growing share of americans
who say
they use youtube but facebook remains
one of the most widely used platforms
among us adults
because they're cord cutting who's oh
they're cord cutting
so they're watching youtube but i feel
like that's the just the younger
generation right
and the younger generation is becoming
more and more and it's rise because the
old people are dying off
all right let's not get that just it's a
scientific fact
so a majority of 18 to 29 year old
adults say they
use instagram which is 71 or snapchat 65
while roughly half say the same for tick
tock
interesting all right let's get to the
story of the day shaquille o'neal
saw a man buying an engagement ring and
decided
to pay for it shaq yup that's what he
did
he uh he paid for the young man's ring
in full
listen i don't forget this story shaq
you're a good guy i like that you did
this amazing
you got the viral video it's awesome let
me tell you guys something about these
engagement rings
it's like another language this is the
biggest racket in the world
it is a racket if you're a man and
you've bought an engagement ring you
know what i'm talking about
if you do not you've not been through
this experience let me tell you about
this racket
they're going to try to pull on you once
tell them what is it for they got
sv1 cl2 i'm like y'all speaking a
different language trying to confuse me
just so you can get more money out of me
so you know what i did i have a friend
he's an expert i said expert boy
you should help me do this and you know
what he said to me do you want sl one
seven g4 i was like no i just want the
thing that she wants
he designed the ring himself guys facts
well of course
of course like if i'm gonna buy
something i'm gonna make sure it's
custom duh but
it's a racket it is a rack about what
they told you about the four c's
is it the four c's or five c i'm not
even going to give that guy a time of
day
all right some guy was telling me some
baloney and i hear it and i said to him
cut
and cartier yeah and guess what i did
that
dude literally told me that and i walked
out i said cartier yo
butt back to your desk i got i'm going
somewhere else
it's lunch money time hashtag ask lm in
the comments below
sloane spiller says pomp i hate to break
it to you but it's definitely pimp's
show
your last name is spiller i like that
spiller
what's your last name your last name all
right
moist nose continues
day 93 of commenting with all due
respect i'm not sure what message
bankrupt means but it sounds like cap
do you know what cap means uh true oh
no cap means no lies oh that's what it
is i read the internet yeah shout out
perhaps you're testing
my grit and seeing if i will give up
hell nah
i'm out here orange filling everyone my
circle friends family and passerby's
alike
i live and breathe there's an e in
breath
moist breathe uh bitcoin
bring me into your world pomp it's
technically a comma after world 2 but uh
now i'm just hashtag built different
that's why i like moist
all right i'm going to do it i know i
got to do it i just
the devil trying to get me moist you
know what it's like they is trying
it's trying my parents are here but
they're not gonna come over here they're
over there my brother is here all these
people keep showing up
doing things i had to go eat pizza last
night life is wild my hair is crazy look
at this
i got all cleavage going on my life's in
shambles but i got the friday energy
forget the racket of engagement rings
sloane spiller we're gonna have problems
i don't even know who you are but i got
problems with you
my loving wife's here see you on monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends